it was May of last year when the highly
addictive and slightly broken dabbler
three fell into our laps and myself and
my co-workers Edmund trend Dan Kapini
and Randolph Ramsey got stuck into the
demon riddled world in a really big way
since I spent last week telling you what
co-op games are worth playing I figured
this week I tell you how to be an
awesome cop companion or at least how to
find the best way to put up with
everybody else if you're throwing dozens
of hours into a game first up are your
standard requirements for similarities
these basically little down to your play
style especially if you're getting stuck
into a meaty game like Diablo 3 there's
no point pairing up you're impatient
buddy with the one who hates any corner
of the map sting unexplored or barrels
sitting on crushed as long as there have
been video games there have been those
who are keen to blitz through them and
others who savor every meaningless
minion kill and I'm sure you know which
of those categories you fall into to
optimize your playing experience it's
probably best to stick with friends who
value the same things as you for example
I found myself frequently left behind
while spending 30 minutes optimizing my
dear or reconfiguring my stats then
you've got those people who are really
keen on watching every cutscene and
talking to every NPC that's a fine way
to play that it can quickly turn a co-op
campaign Sal well for the gamer who
really wants to just plow through to the
next objective best way to keep
everybody happy in that case is to make
sure everyone's on the same page with
how you're gonna play and that nobody
gets left behind similarities among call
plays are super important but for many
games there's a huge advantage to
highlighting your differences games like
try and demand that each player embody a
totally different hero fenders left 4
dead 2 where players can differentiate
themselves by their weapon choice having
someone rock the shotgun ensures they
can make short work of any clothes
zombie encounters while the rest pick
them off at range torchlight and Diablo
don't have these
restrictions but it sure does make for a
more interesting group if you don't have
full witch doctors for my diablo 3
playthrough i had my heart set on a dual
blade wielding monk unfortunately
everybody else found in affinity for a
different class if you and a bunch of
friends are taking on a team fortress 2
map you'll probably have more luck
winning with a diverse array of skill
sets as opposed to just being a gang of
Pyro's although that would be freaking
awesome lastly and this covers an awful
lot of games is the importance of being
a good communicator whether you have a
skype setup a service like mumble or
some other way to get your voice into
somebody else's ear holes it's a very
good way to stay on top of your group
campaign this is hugely important for
games like model too if you need more
than just a timer and a Hey look over
there button valve we've unfortunately
unable to find the time to implement the
stop what you're trying it's stupid and
move to the other side of the map you
dolt button FPS games like Borderlands 2
and halo are always better when you can
keep lines of communication open since
they're generally very fast-paced when
standard voice commands and high-fives
work cut it a direct way to tell your
buddy to haul ass to the front line is
superbly useful let me know in the
comments what you reckon the most
important rule is for being a good cop
gamer and I will catch you next week